Hello everyone. Welcome to a new episode of The
Dissenter. I'm your host, as always, Ricardo Lops, and
today I'm joined by Dr. Neil Sinnababu. He's an
associate professor in the department of philosophy at the
National University of Singapore, and today we're talking about
his book, Nietzsche on the Eternal Recurrence. So Neil,
welcome to the show. It's a pleasure to everyone.
Uh, THANK you for having me. Hello, viewers.
So,
first,
uh, to start off with, what is really the
idea of the eternal return or the eternal recurrence?
I mean, could you explain it to us?
Uh, YES, the idea is that, uh, the universe
will go in a sort of cyclical fashion where,
uh, everything that happened, uh, uh, before, well, uh,
uh, it's, uh, will, will have, uh, these lives
that we have right now. We have them, we've
had them many times. BEFORE we will have them
many times again. All the events that proceed from
the present will sort of loop back to the
present, and the future will be a series of
sort of loops of the same thing happening over
and over again just as the past was. So
the course of time through eternity proceeds in a
circle with the same events happening over and over.
And does this have anything to do with the
nature of the universe itself?
Indeed, it is a distinctly cosmological hypothesis. It's a
claim that the universe will take this kind of
course, uh, looping back on itself with the same
events over and over.
So what are then the cosmological arguments for the
eternal recurrence?
Yes, so there are two premises of the argument
for the eternal recurrence. Uh, FIRST, uh, time is
infinite. Uh, AND second, that the number of configurations
of matter in space are finite. So the way
these come together is if you have infinite time
and a finite number of configurations of matter in
space, uh, in that case, to fill up infinite
time, you have to repeat some configurations. So that
will give you some kind of eternal recurrence where
the same state has to be returned to. A
third assumption that puts everything into very orderly cycles
of recurrence, where everything loops and that's all you
get is determinism, because then if you return to
a previous state, you get the state that followed
that and the state that followed that, and if
you have one loop, you just keep on. Getting
loops through that deterministic, uh, process. Uh, SO, Nietzsche
accepted all three of those assumptions. You just need
the first two to get, uh, the present state
will occur, but with all three, you get, uh,
the structure of, uh, time and space organized into
neat recurring loops.
Mhm. And is this, uh, idea, the uh Nietzsche's
idea of the eternal recurrence of scientific hypo hypothesis
in any way.
He certainly thought so, and he attempted to demonstrate
it from scientific premises that were reasonable to accept
at the time, infinite time and some of the
things that would get us to a nonfinite set
of configurations, for example, an eternally expanding universe, those
things we believe in now. Uh, PERHAPS an eternally
expanding universe. I believe that's sort of what the
cosmologists who study the universe are telling us, but
that was not something known in Nietzsche's time in
the 1880s when he was working on this. So
he worked for the science of his day, which
also included determinism, at least that was a widely
accepted view, and he just put things together that
were reasonable to believe from science at his time
and got to this conclusion.
So what early statements about the eternal return can
be found in gay science, and is that the
work where we can first find the idea of
the eternal recurrence mentioned in any way?
Yes, that is his first published work in which
it appears. Uh, HE, he has some unpublished notes
in which it appears, but as far as sort
of a, uh, meant for public consumption, uh, uh,
uh, description of the eternal recurrence, yes, that's, uh,
that's the place he would go. Uh, SO why
don't I, uh, uh, uh, if you'd like, I
could, I could read out the, uh, first appearance
of the. Internal recurrence in his published works. Yeah,
this is the first, uh, clear, uh, thing he
says. It occurs involving a conversation, uh, uh, sort
of, it's very hypothetical involves, uh, what if a
demon spoke to you? Here's how it goes, here's
how it goes. What if some day or night,
a demon were to steal after you into your
loneliest loneliness and say to you, This life as
you now live it and have lived it. You
will have to live once more and innumerable times
more, and there will be nothing new in it,
but every pain and every joy and every thought
and sigh and everything unutterably small or great in
your life will have to return to you in
the same succession and sequence, even this spider and
this moonlight between the trees and even this moment
and I myself. The eternal hourglass of existence is
turned upside down again and again, and you with
it speck of dust. So that expresses the idea
of, uh, you know, everything coming back again and
again, and then from there, uh, Nietzsche considers how
would we respond to this. He asks, would you
not throw yourself down and gnash your teeth and
curse the demon who spoke thus, or have you
once experienced a tremendous moment when you would have
answered him? You are a god, and nothing, never
have I heard anything more divine. Um, SO, uh,
N Nietzsche presents that cosmological hypothesis, which he takes
to be scientific, and he says, well, what if,
you know, hypothetically a demon were to tell you
that this is the way it's going to be?
Uh, WELL, would you, uh, be, uh, uh, horrified
by this? Would this be, uh, something terrible to
you, or would you think this is the most
wonderful thing, and I'm very happy, demon, for getting
this news? Uh, THAT'S sort of the question that
he's putting there.
Yeah, and I guess that will also go through
how we then deal, uh, how he then reacts
to his own what we would now call thought
experiment in the spoke Zarathustra, but, uh, in the
book, you also compare the idea of the eternal
recurrence to Juan Care's uh theorem. So what, how
do you compare it there?
Ah yes, so I'm guided here by the work
of the physicist Stephen Brush, who describes Nietzsche's idea
of the eternal recurrence as a qualitative anticipation of
Paul and Care's theorem. So the two essential premises
that time is infinite and there are a finite
number of configurations, things pretty close to that come
up in Poin-Cre's theorem. To describe a couple of
differences, Poincare is working with an indeterminis, indeterministic system,
so he will get a sort of jagged recurrence
where Things don't work in neat loops, but things
will eventually come back to each configuration. You won't
get the same stories over and over again until
an enormous amount of time passes, and then by
randomness you might get something that's the same, at
least for human purposes. The other thing that Poincare
assumes it's a little bit different from Nietzsche is
he doesn't have things going exactly back to the
same positions. But he does have them getting so
close that from the human point of view we
might not be able to see any differences, and
if we get that for the purpose of human
life, it just looks like recurrence, and I don't
know if Nietzsche would draw any differences there because
from the human point of view, everything is just
exactly the same.
By the way, as a scientific hypothesis, as the
eternal recurrence been validated, is it something that physicists,
for example, expect to happen or not?
No, not in our current understanding of the universe,
because of things like, for one thing, the expanding
universe. For a second thing, I mean, the deterministic
assumption does not accord with the foundations of quantum
mechanics as we understand them. So there's a bunch
of little ways in which things are going differently
from the way that Nietzsche thought they would go
and the way that a late 1800s physic. Is
thought they would go. Here Nietzsche is working within
the science of his times, and he was actually
very knowledgeable about science as it was in his
times. Despite being trained in classical philology rather than
the natural sciences. He did try to understand scientific
results. He was familiar, for example, with the 2nd
law of thermodynamics as expressed by Lord Kelvin. Or
William Thompson. So those kinds of things he did
know about, but that is not the science of
today. The expanding universe is sort of the big
thing that I talk about in the book as
a clear way of showing that the eternal recurrence
doesn't accord with contemporary science, because things are just
getting bigger and bigger. You don't go back to
the same small state before. So unfortunately that can
block it. Yeah,
so tell us about attitudinal and normative interpretations of
the eternal recurrence.
Yes, these are the popular interpretations, or at least
in the scholarly literature for the last couple decades.
So, Stephen Brush, the physicist who is connecting Nietzsche
to Poincare, wrote in the 1970s, but Nietzsche scholars
over the last several decades have not been picking
up on that very much. There's a long tradition.
Equally significant in this tradition is Alexander Nehemas. There's
many philosophers who have followed him who say N
Nietzsche's point wasn't to present this as a cosmological
hypothesis. The attitudinal, attitudinal and normative interpretations basically have
ways of using this for certain kinds of broadly
evaluative purposes. So an attitudinal. Interpretation would say, uh,
this is a test of how good your attitudes
are. Like, what kind of person are you? Are
you sort of, uh, uh, disposed well towards the
world? Well, then you'll have a positive attitude towards
this. Then you'll be so well disposed towards life
that you will say, uh, you know, I want
to live life again and again. And Nietzsche sees
that as a very healthy way to look at
the world. Um, BUT suppose you don't like life.
Suppose you're unhappy with this world, and you're like,
Oh, no, I'm condemned to live again and again.
How terrible. Well, Nietzsche thinks that your system of
attitudes then has a problem. You're just not loving
life enough. Um, AND so, the attitudinal interpretation looks
at this in terms of sort of, does, what
does this say about your attitudes and you? Are
you loving life sufficiently? So that's the attitudinal one,
and the normative interpretation is kind of similar in
that it sort of gives evaluations of what you're
doing. It says, uh, Really, you should try to
live your life so that you would want everything
to happen over and over again. And there is
something kind of like that, uh, that Nietzsche may
have, you know, thought of and thought, OK, that'd
be a pretty healthy way to live, where I'd
want all of these things to go on over
and over again. There are things to suggest that
he, uh, thought favorably of that. Um, uh, SO
I think those, uh, Interpretations are, you know, to
some extent correct. They're describing real things in the
text. The problem is if they try to claim
that they are totally complete and that they're giving
you everything in the text and they exclude the
cosmological interpretation, I think there's a mistake there. This
is not being presented in a merely hypothetical way
as something that Nietzsche thinks, oh, that's never going.
To happen, but it's a good test. It's something
that I think N Nietzsche thought was a legitimate
scientific hypothesis. I don't think he was certain of
it because the assumptions are just so heavy and
so difficult that Nietzsche, not being a scientist, I
think he was aware that he couldn't prove these
things, but it was a scientific hypothesis that had
strong support from the science Nietzsche knew. And he
wasn't, you know, mistaken in thinking that Poincare's theorem
kind of shows how close he got. Poincare, the
sad story is Poincare did get his, uh, got
the King Oscar of Sweden Prize in 1889 for.
Uh, PROVING this theorem, he got out on January
in the 20th of January in 1889. Unfortunately, N
Nietzsche had gone insane in Turin on January 3rd
or 4th, January 3rd, 1 of those days. So
he had he had gotten insane just within the
month. If he had just been able to sort
of keep his sanity for a few more weeks,
for another month, we could have had Nietzsche discovering
that a scientific discovery that proceeded from his premises
had been sort of validated by the scientific authorities
of his day, and what he would have written
then, what he would have thought then would have
been beautiful to see. So looking back at Stephen
Brush's work, which likens these two discoveries to each
other. That really got me to think, well, um,
We need to show the people who are using
merely attitudinal and merely normative interpretations of the eternal
recurrence that there's really more there and that there's
a big story to be told about N Nietzsche
tracking the science of his time and then finding
something. It was at least a reasonable speculation.
Mhm. Yeah, that's very interesting. And what kinds of
psychological effects does the idea of the eternal recurrence
have on people? I mean, are they the ones
predicted by Nietzsche in that quote you read from
Gay Science, or are they different?
Well, people have all kinds of, uh, different reactions
to it. Uh, uh, SO, uh, uh, I've talked
to people who find it horrifying. I personally, uh,
I'm very happy with, uh, my life, uh, philosophy.
It's very fun to do and, uh, is a
wonderful thing. And if I were to live again
and again, I think, uh, despite bad things that
happen in my life, uh, as bad things happen
in all our lives, I think I would be
quite happy, uh, uh, with the eternal recurrence. I
might be very unhappy on behalf of other people
because I know many people have lived very miserable
lives, and for them I would feel very bad
for them to be trapped in this repeated terrible
existence. Uh, SO that's really the downside of it,
just how much misery other people would be locked
into. For myself, I would be pretty happy for,
you know, all sentient beings in creation as a
whole. How do I, how should I feel for
them? Well, I guess that depends on how sentient
creation. AS a whole goes, you know, how the,
you know, everything that exists, uh, how I, you
know, everything in the universe. Should I believe that,
uh, I guess if one cycle is good, many
cycles would be infinitely good, uh, if that's how
it turns out, if one cycle is net good,
that's how things score for infinity. Of course, if
one cycle is net bad, uh, we get a
hellish negative score over the course of infinity of,
you know, infinite negative value, infinite badness, um. So
a lot will depend on how your life is,
on how you see the prospects for the lives
of others. If you are an altruistic or empathic
kind of person. All those things will come together
to determine how you feel. There is also an
opinion held by many Nietzsche scholars that this shouldn't
make too much of a difference. Difference. Um, SOME
people have expressed this in thinking, OK, well, if
it's just the same life over and over again,
and it's going to happen over and over again,
why should I really care? I can't do anything
about it. I think that's actually a mistaken response.
Uh, YOU should care for the same reason that
you would care about an eternal afterlife, either in
heaven or hell. That you could not do anything
about. For example, if I came to know that
there was nothing I could do and I would
be uh tormented forever with eternal damnation, uh, if
I discovered that if the demon whispered that to
me, I would be rather horrified and I would,
I suppose, try to enjoy my remaining time on
Earth and make the most of it, but I
would have something really terrible to fear afterwards that
would go on forever. So that would be a,
a, a terrible thing to discover. And if, uh,
uh, on the other hand, I had heavenly bliss
going on for forever, uh, I would be delighted,
uh, if there were a god that would give
such a thing to be. I would, of course,
be overjoyed with that god. Sadly, I do not
believe that, uh, uh, uh, there is such a
God, but fortunately, I don't think there was a
devil that will torment me in eternal hell either.
Um, SO, uh, You know, for the reasons that
an eternal heaven is wonderful and an eternal hell
is terrible, even if you can't do anything about
them, uh, the same way, an eternity of this
life over and over again could be wonderful or
terrible, uh, depending on how this life is.
Right, so let's talk about the spoke Zarathustra and
what we can find there about the eternal recurrence.
So what can we find there exactly? What is
the story there?
Yes, so the story begins roughly halfway through the
text. So, uh, the prologue and section one are
Zarathustra expressing a whole bunch of views that give
you his general philosophy on a number of different
topics. Uh, THEN late in section two of part
two of this book, Zarathustra, sorry, part two, I
should say, we have, um, In a section called
the soothsayer, there is a soothsayer who talks to
Zarathustra and expresses this sort of dark prophecy of
what the future will be like, what the soothsayer
is. Saying to everybody in his uh uh Doc
prophecy is, and I saw a great sadness descend
upon mankind. The best grew wary of their works.
A doctrine appeared accompanied by a faith. All is
empty. All is the same. All has been. So
that's a way of saying something that the eternal
recurrence would make true. All is empty. All is
the same. All has been. Well, everything that we're
doing has happened many times before. Now he adds
the all is empty because he sees that as
empty of value. We're just trapped in a valueless
existence over and over and over, and he describes
sort of poetically what people are saying about this.
People are very unhappy in the soothsayer's vision. Uh,
THEY are saying things like, Alas, where is there
still a sea in which one might drown? Thus
we are wailing across shallow swamps. Verily, we have
become too wary even to die. We are still
waking and living on in tombs. So this is
sort of the dark future that Zarathustra sees if
the eternal recurrence is widely accepted and known by
people. You know, Zarathustra himself doesn't really internalize immediately
at that point that the soothsayer is suggesting the
eternal occurrence. What actually happens there is Zarathustra hears
the soothsayer's words. It disturbs. These words disturb him,
and then he goes into this deep sleep and
has a dream. He has a dream. About being
a night watchman and a guardian of tombs upon
the lonely mountain castle of death. These tombs have
life that had been overcome. The castle has the
odor of dusty eternities, and all this stuff, you
know, Nietzsche scholars have not always looked at this
section as being about the eternal recurrence, but this
mountain castle of death where Nietzsche dreams about being
for dusty eternities after hearing the all is wary,
all the same, all has been prophecy. That, you
know, on, I guess my second reading of the
book, uh, pretty quickly, looked like the eternal recurrence
to me. The first time it's hard to see
because you don't know about the eternal recurrence when
you hit that, but, uh, that really looked very
eternal recurrency, and then when I looked at the
science of it and all that, I was like,
OK, the lonely mountain castle of death he's describing,
he's sort of imagining seeing the world. IN all
the dark parts where there are no living beings
and everything is sort of on its way back
to where the living beings will be and thrive.
So that's how I understood this passage that the
soothsayer in giving this prophecy has sort of planted
the seed of the idea in Zarathustra's mind. It
emerges in a dream. Now Zarathustra doesn't even understand
his dream. Uh, WHEN he wakes up, uh, he
wakes up basically because the dream ends with the
roaring wind blowing one of the coffins open and
crazy things fly out of the coffin. They are
uh uh butterflies and owls and uh. Just all
kinds of crazy things. Everything's flying out of the
coffin. That frightens him and he wakes up. He
asks his disciples, what was my dream about? Please
try to interpret it. A disciple gives an interpretation
that's obviously wrong. Zarathustra shakes his head, but the
they have dinner with the soothsayer. That's basically what
happens there. So Zarathustra doesn't even understand it, and
the way this goes in the book is for
the next couple sections, he increasingly just begins to
realize what it was he saw in his vision.
He gets the idea of the eternal recurrence, and
it horrifies him. It horrifies him because if everything
is coming back again and again, the first thing
that strikes him is that the bad things will
come back again and again, and then he will
have infinite badness over the course of all the
time there is with all the bad things eternally
recurring. Uh, SO that's sort of the initial sort
of struggle he has with it.
Yeah, but, but, so how exactly does he deal
with the idea of all bad events in life
repeating themselves and the resulting infinite negative value?
Yeah, so this is something that, uh, over the
course of, uh, uh, part two and part three,
so part two we see him descend into his
like horror and depression about this, uh, part three
begins with him, uh, uh, very, uh, uh, sad
and depressed. At the end of part two, there
is this sort of magical voice that speaks to
him, his stillest hour that tells him to go
off by himself into solitude, and the reason he's
going off by himself into solitude, it's basically the
place that he's going to be able to sort
of come to terms with the idea of the
eternal recurrence. So he has more sort of visions
of this. The idea becomes clear to him. He
thinks about it more. After, as time passes, the
process by which he comes to terms with the
eternal recurrence is, well, there's infinite negative value, and
that initially shocks him and makes him horrified with
the idea, but after that, he eventually becomes, you
know, becomes aware of the infinite positive value that
the eternal recurrence makes available as well, and it's
sort of both things are playing on his desires,
dispositions, feelings at the same time. Uh, SO all
of that is sort of operating on him, and
the story is that in the end, his dispositions
and attitudes towards the positive value went out, uh,
and that's why he comes to love the eternal
recurrence.
But how is it that he comes to recognize
infinite positive value then and how does he relate
to life afterwards?
Yes, so, uh, uh, this, uh, within the story,
it's, it's sort of a, uh, there's a period
for which he thinks about it. There's periods for
which he travels through human society. There's sort of
a pause in the eternal recurrent story during part
three where he considers a bunch of other matters,
and then he goes up to his. Cave in
the mountains. Zarathustra, being a a sort of a
colorful sort of hero, has all these animal friends
that include an eagle and a serpent, the eagle
being the proudest and most courageous animal, the serpent
being the wisest animal, and he goes up to
his mountain cave with them. And at one point
he decides, you know, OK, this is the time
to confront my abysmal thought, the abysmal thought of
all the bad things, including, particularly this is sort
of a distinctive bad thing that Zarathustra is very
focused on, the eternal recurrence of contemptible people coming
back over and over again. And given that Zarathustra
is sort of a fan of human excellence, having
contemptible people eternally recur. IS something he's not very
happy about. So it's sort of disgust with that,
uh, that, uh, sort of, uh, uh, uh, is
his abysmal thought. Now, for me, I, I'm kind
of not too worried about contemptible people. I don't
really think about, you know, that kind of problem
too much, but, you know, human suffering and animal
suffering, I do think about. So that's what it
would be for me that I'd just be horrified
by. But, you know, Zarathustra has his own reasons
for horror. So he just sort of faces up
to his thought. This cave, and it's sort of
uh makes him fall unconscious and leaves him sort
of a comatose, unable to move about for a
whole week, uh, when even after he regains consciousness,
he just lies there on the floor of his
cave. And at the end of the week, he,
uh, finally sort of wakes up and his animals
have brought him, uh, they're very nice animals. They've
brought him all kinds of foods, and he sort
of, uh, uh, smells one of the rose apples
and it's kind of nice, and his animals were
like, Oh, you're back. OK, uh, uh, why don't
you wake up and see all the wonderful things
in the world? And what's happened over those seven
days, I think, is that, uh, all his dispositions,
the negative and the positive, he sort of, you
know, had to sort of imagine eternity. And sort
of All those dispositions in him, his negative and
positive attitudes towards life, have sort of uh both
sort of found their objects in eternity, and one
has won out over the other as far as
the preponderance of attitudes goes, and the positive attitudes
in the end have won. The world on the
whole eternally. Occurring looks beautiful enough to him that
the infinite positive value suddenly is looking like, well,
something much more beautiful than you could ever have
in a single life. You see that infinite positive
value, and he wants his life to eternally recur
at this point. There's a wonderful romantic drama where
Life, who has been Zarathustra's love interest throughout some
of the most pretty sections of the book, sort
of appears again. He goes through this wild dance
with her that is a little bit violent that
kind of expresses, I think, just like how life
has its ups and downs, and life will sometimes
slap you and life will. Uh, SOMETIMES kiss you
and it'll do all these different things, and, uh,
life has all these kind of effects on him
and in the end he decides, or it's, it's
sort of in him that he, you know, loves
life and wants to, uh, in one of the
nice metaphors at the end of part three, give,
I think, life the ring of. Recurrence as a
sort of a, a wedding ring, and I think
the way that this goes in the, in the
story of the book is, uh, life, once given
the ring of recurrence, uh, uh, and married to
Zarathustra, her married name is eternity because Zarathustra is,
uh, well, together, uh, for, you know, he's living
for eternity and life. Comes eternal life. Uh, THAT'S
uh uh how Zarathustra is supposed to sort of
get into a permanent, uh, forever relationship with life.
Um, AND, uh, part three of Zarathustra ends with
what most readers consider the climax of the book
where, uh, Zarathustra is proclaiming, uh, uh. Uh, THE
7 things about his life, uh, that make it
worth living again and again, and, uh, every one
he ends with, for I love you, O eternity.
Mhm. So, but then what is his first public
statement about the eternal recurrence?
Uh, SO, well, uh, as far as public statements
about it go, uh, he makes some public statements
initially, for example, in reporting his dream, that he
doesn't even know about the eternal recurrence. Uh, HE'S
just like, I had this dream, and people can't
interpret exactly what it is, but it is about
that. That's sort of what he's seeing in his
vision. The second statement, and the clearest public statement
is about a second vision he has, uh, in
which he's carrying a dwarf up a mountain. And
the dwarf is named the Spirit of gravity. Uh,
THIS is sort of a, the dwarf is sort
of weighing on his shoulders and weighing him down,
uh, but he has to carry this heavy dwarf
up the mountain. The dwarf is taunting him, uh,
basically about how, uh, bad things are and uh
trying to sort of uh uh uh depress him
as the spirit of gravity would, and try to
bring him down in a literal sense, uh. He
basically describes this vision of the dwarf. At a
certain point, he carries the dwarf up to this
gateway that he finds up in the mountain, and
he sees this path leading to the gateway. There
is sort of a path leading beyond the gateway.
He imagines sort of an infinite path and thinks,
well, if we have this infinite path. Uh, THEN,
you know, whatever is going on over there and
whatever is behind, uh, if there is a finite
number of configurations of matter, you will have to
repeat things to fill a space on both sides
of the infinite path, and that's sort of his.
The clearest description of the eternal recurrence that includes
the premises he shares with Poincare, the infinite time,
the necessity of repetition along that infinite path. Now
the interesting thing about the dwarf that was on
his shoulders is as Zarathustra comes to terms with
the eternal recurrence, comes to explicitly see it, comes
to just state that this is going to happen,
the dwarf seems to become lighter and lighter. On
his shoulders and eventually vanishes and here we see,
I think, the dwarf as a sort of projection
of sort of Zarathustra's negative attitudes, the attitudes that
would bring him down as the attitudes that uplift
him become stronger than those as that balance towards
the eternal recurrence slowly shifts, we see the dwarf
start to diminish and vanish. Mhm.
So what goals did you have in mind with
this book?
Yeah, well. The biggest goal of mine was just
to tell the story of the eternal recurrence. I,
you know, Zarathustra, this book Zarathustra is Uh, uh,
probably my favorite book. The other, uh, a contender
would be The Fellowship of the Ring, which I
read when I was, uh, in 8th grade. But
yeah, as far as the books that made me,
there's those two. AND, uh, when I was 19
years old, you know, as an undergraduate, these ideas
of the eternal recurrence in Zarathustra sort of occurred
to me, and I was fascinated with the story.
Uh, YOU know, there's just so much about it
that's amazing. Here we have a sort of secular
proposal for it. Eternal life, you know, you don't
have to have a God giving you heaven or
threatening you with hell, you know, if this worked
out here in the world, we would have sort
of a system that gives you eternal life, and
I was just obsessed with those books, Zarathustra. I
loved this book. I would just read it again
and again. My undergraduate friends knew me as completely
crazy about it. So I saw this story then.
I'd never had a proper opportunity to tell the
story, and I just had that. Story and me
ready to tell this Cambridge Elements series that the
book is in is this nice series of short
books that just fit the size of the story.
I had to tell perfectly. So if any viewers
want to see the story, this Cambridge Element Nietzsche
and The Eternal Recurrence is just very, very easy
to get online or if you want the paper
copy, you can get that too. It's available in
paper form as well, whatever you like. Yeah, uh,
and so it was mostly to tell that story,
and, you know, there's, there's, uh, things like, uh,
the scholarly literature had, even, you know, these are
Nietzsche scholars. This is our guy, you know, and
if the physicists are telling us, you know, he
had a really neat scientific idea that uh was
this just really nice qualitative anticipation of an important
scientific result for which one of the great scientists
at the time won a prize that was being
awarded for sort of the best discovery, you know,
across all of Europe that anyone could find. OK,
well, you know, we better know that. We better,
you know, as Nietzsche scholars, give our guy some
credit, and it's, you know, while I, you know,
respect all the scholars who came before and did
all the work to defend the attitudinal and, and,
and normative interpretations, there's something they're getting at that
is part of the picture. Well, if we're neglecting
this huge thing that Nietzsche discovered. The physicists are
telling us, you know, is so amazing. It was
for me, it was a revelation looking at Stephen
Brush's old book because Brush was writing this giant,
like 800 page history of statistical mechanics and how
laws about gasses and heat and all these things
were developed, and three pages are on Nietzsche because
N Nietzsche made this qualitative anticipation of Poincare's theorem.
And, you know, that's something that the community of
Nietzsche scholars really needs to appreciate, and we need
to be able to boast about our man properly,
you know, if he did this, we should be
able to say it. Um, ALSO, uh, uh, there
are physicists who sometimes these days, uh, go back
to Nietzsche and see that. They're like, hey, look,
this is, this is interesting. Uh, THE physicist Sean
Carroll had a blog post, noting that, uh, yeah,
this Nietzsche. Stuff looks a lot like Poincare, and
the literature and philosophy hadn't really picked up on
that. So, you know, I thought we've got to
sort of like, yeah, tell the physicists that they're
getting this right and make all of that clear,
uh, make it clear just how much N Nietzsche
was doing. We sort of owe that to our
hero as Nietzsche scholars, you know, and, and just
as scholars trying to get the, the truth about
what happened back then out to everybody. So there's
those kinds of things. There's also just the fact,
and this just comes back to telling the story.
I find the story, uh, once you see how
it all fits together, just a really neat story
about how one can come to love life with
this amazing thing about infinity before one, and there
are just these incredibly poignant moments in it. So
this is a a moment from a Zarathustra and
that late conversation with life. So, uh, what is
going on right before he proclaims the eternal recurrence
is there's this section where he and life are
together and um Uh, uh Uh, life says to
him, Oh, Zarathustra, you are not faithful enough to
me. You do not love me nearly as much
as you say. I know you are thinking of
leaving me soon, and here I think Zarathustra, what
she's realizing is Zarathustra is a mortal man. He's
going to leave her, um, and yeah, that's we
leave life when we die, um. And uh uh
Zarathustra replies, yes, but you also know, and he
whispers something in her ear. And there's some debate
among scholars who, uh, uh, about what exactly he
whispers to her because we don't know, but the,
um, the, I think the, uh, uh, most standard
interpretation and the one I accept is that he
whispers something meaning. But I will return And that's
what the eternal recurrence would say. Um, WE don't
know exactly what he says. This isn't included in
the text, so that's sort of an interpreter's mystery,
but the, uh, uh, uh, reply that she gives,
uh, to him is, you know that. O Zarathustra?
But nobody knows that. And so what seems to
be happening is life herself is telling Zarathustra about
the uncertainty of the eternal recurrence, and this is
the kind of thing that makes me think N
Nietzsche himself was uncertain about it, realizing that he
could not demonstrate that the scientific premises were true,
but there was a conjecture that made sense given
the scientific sciences of his times, given things that
he was not in any position to prove. He
didn't have Poincare's. Scientific abilities. He didn't have the
mathematic abilities of Konstantin Kraheodori, who is the great
mathematician who eventually basically gave the final version of
the math for Poincare's theorem. He, you know, he
can't do this, so he doesn't know for sure,
and life is actually telling him that. But then
the last line there after life says that to
him is from Zarathustra saying or to himself just
in his mind. But then life was dearer to
me than all my wisdom ever was. And I
think what Zarathustra himself is sort of saying back
or he's sort of realizing is, you know, I
want to live again because I love life so
much, you know, and I said this confidently to
life sort of out of a kind of wishful
thinking because I just love life so much. I
can't bear to be without life, you know, it
means so much to me. I'm no longer in
the situation where I'm horrified by the eternal occurrence.
I wanted just to love because I love life
and want to be with life forever. So he's
expressing that kind of desire to be with life
again and again, and it's so strong in him
that even like his knowledge that this is uncertain.
Yeah, that kind of fades away behind him, just
the way that he just can't bear to think
of it because he loves life so much. So
that's just such a beautiful scene, and I want
people to understand that scene and appreciate it. So
writing this book so that people would be able
to make sense of the story and make sense
of all the beauty of the story, just doing
that sort of so Nietzsche's message could come out
so that he could, people could see this, people
could see how all the symbols in the book
and all this beautiful stuff are expressing this amazing
message about loving life. That was the point, you
know, and I hope people will be able to
see the story and appreciate that.
OK, so one final question then. What would you
say is the current, the contemporary relevance of the
idea of the eternal recurrence since as we talked
about earlier, it has not been validated scientifically? I
mean, what would you say about that?
Yeah, it's a good question. Uh, I mean, and
this is, uh, I suppose, uh, maybe to be
discovered to a large extent, you know, after my,
you know, book comes out, we'll see what the
literature does with it, what people develop out of
it, uh, that remains to be seen. Um, AND
I, I have been very happy with the initial
sort of responses, uh, I mean, there's not much
published because, uh, uh. Uh, YOU know, the book
is just so new. It just came out this
year. Um, uh, BUT, uh, you know, there's people
like, uh, uh, Simon Goldstein at Hong Kong University
who've taken interest in the eternal recurrence, you had
some early mention of this kind of stuff, uh,
who are not N Nietzsche scholars, but who are
just like, OK, it's good to work out what
happens in a circular time kind of framework and
how infinities might arise. There's a lot of, uh,
uh, uh, uh, philosophers, including many in my department,
who are interested in issues of, uh, what. Happens
in an infinite reality, you know, if, if things
are infinite in some kind of way, well, what
do we make of that for a bunch of
ethical issues? And this is a contribution to that
discussion. There's also, uh, so the eternal recurrence is
sort of a story about, well, if the eternal
recurrence is true, it's that reality in a temporal
way ends up being very large, or sort of
the reality that's like. Um, THE world humans live
in ends up being in a certain sense, very
large in its extension across time. Uh, THERE are
other theories in physics that make, uh, the human-like
reality very large as well, like multiverse theories, uh,
in physics, uh, or even in philosophy if you
have David Lewis's view. Um, THESE multiverse theories just
say that there's a lot of human-like environments in
reality. That's sort of the ethically significant point. So
there are just many others out there somewhere, including
maybe others that are very much like us. So
there's this interesting question, sort of like from an
ethical, personal point of view, uh, how should we
regard in a very large reality, the many others,
you know, they won't interact with us. There's nothing
they can do to change our situation because they're
just too far away or they're at different times.
But it's sort of an interesting question. How should
we feel about their presence, you know, well, the
thing I think we should feel is, I think
we should hope that all goes well for them.
Uh, ALL these beings that might be somewhere out
there. I, I mean, I can't affect anything about
them, but I wish them well. I hope they
are happy. Uh, I would be very sad if
there were just hells out there somewhere in reality,
and there is nothing that can be done and
beings are in torment. I mean, we do have
that in some unfortunate parts of the reality we
know. Hopefully we can fix problems where people are
suffering terribly or animals are suffering. Terribly and do
that, but in the cases that are far away,
there is nothing we can do. At least I
think we should sort of hope that things go
better. Yeah, there is nothing we can do to
act, but our feelings are still appropriate about those
faraway things. So just in sort of thinking through
and understanding how to feel about a very large
reality with many others who may be like us.
In some ways, but we cannot affect. Uh, THE
eternal recurrence is one of the ideas that sort
of, uh, uh, sort of an early sort of,
uh, idea that emerges from a certain kind of
scientific picture that allows us to play around with
that, to understand it. Maybe some of the lessons
will be more broadly applicable, applicable to these other
large reality theories if they are true.
OK, so the book is again Nietzsche on the
eternal recurrence. I'm leaving a link to it in
the description of the interview. And uh Neil, apart
from the book, would you like to tell people
where they can find your work on the internet?
Uh, YES, I have a Phil Papers page, Phil
Papers, uh, being, I think, the best place for
philosophers to host their research, as, uh, you know,
if you put stuff there, people can download it
for free, uh, and I want people to see
all the cool ideas for free, you know, so,
uh, yeah, please, uh, if you're interested in, uh,
any of the topics I work on, I try
to put everything up there. If there's something I've
worked on. That's not up there, that's a publication,
please let me know if you want it so
that I make sure I put it up there
and make it available. Uh, SO yeah, you can
even get, uh, this book up there if, uh,
if you'd like, uh, and download a PDF. Uh,
PLEASE take a look and, uh, yeah, uh, see
if you would like, uh, the, uh, uh, universe
to eternally recur. I, I hope your life is
going so well that, uh, you would like Zarathustra.
Great, so thank you so much for taking the
time to come on the show. It's been a
real pleasure to talk with you.
Thank you so much for having me here.
Hi guys, thank you for watching this interview until
the end. If you liked it, please share it,
leave a like and hit the subscription button. The
show is brought to you by Enlights Learning and
Development done differently. Check their website at enlights.com and
also please consider supporting the show on Patreon or
PayPal. I would also like to give a huge
thank you to my main patrons and PayPal supporters,
Perergo Larsson, Jerry Muller, Frederick Sundo, Bernard Seyaz Olaf,
Alex, Adam Cassel, Matthew Whittingbird, Arnaud Wolff, Tim Hollis,
Eric Elena, John Connors, Philip Forrest Connolly. Then Dmitri
Robert Windegerru Inasi Zu Mark Nevs, Colin Holbrookfield, Governor,
Michel Stormir, Samuel Andrea, Francis Forti Agnun, Svergoro, and
Hal Herzognon, Michel Jonathan Labrarinth, John Yardston, and Samuel
Curric Hines, Mark Smith, John Ware, Tom Hammel, Sardusran,
David Sloan Wilson, Yasilla Dezara Romain Roach, Diego Londono
Correa. Yannik Punteran Ruzmani, Charlotte Blis Nicole Barbaro, Adam
Hunt, Pavlostazevski, Alec Baka Madison, Gary G. Alman, Semov,
Zal Adrian Yei Poltontin, John Barboza, Julian Price, Edward
Hall, Edin Bronner, Douglas Fry, Franco Bartolotti, Gabriel P
Scortez or Suliliski, Scott Zachary Fish, Tim Duffy, Sony
Smith, and Wiseman. Daniel Friedman, William Buckner, Paul Georg
Jarno, Luke Lovai, Georgios Theophanus, Chris Williamson, Peter Wolozin,
David Williams, Di Acosta, Anton Ericsson, Charles Murray, Alex
Shaw, Marie Martinez, Coralli Chevalier, Bangalore atheists, Larry D.
Lee Junior. Old Eringbon. Esterri, Michael Bailey, then Spurber,
Robert Grassy, Zigoren, Jeff McMahon, Jake Zul, Barnabas Raddix,
Mark Kempel, Thomas Dovner, Luke Neeson, Chris Story, Kimberly
Johnson, Benjamin Galbert, Jessica Nowicki, Linda Brendan, Nicholas Carlson,
Ismael Bensleyman. George Ekoriati, Valentine Steinmann, Per Crawley, Kate
Van Goler, Alexander Obert, Liam Dunaway, BR, Massoud Ali
Mohammadi, Perpendicular, Janus Hetner, Ursula Guinov, Gregory Hastings, David
Pinsov, Sean Nelson, Mike Levin, and Jos Necht. A
special thanks to my producers Iar Webb, Jim Frank,
Lucas Stink, Tom Vanneden, Bernardine Curtis Dixon, Benedict Mueller,
Thomas Trumbull, Catherine and Patrick Tobin, John Carlo Montenegro,
Al Nick Cortiz, and Nick Golden, and to my
executive producers, Matthew Lavender, Sergio Quadrian, Bogdan Kanis, and
Rosie. Thank you for all.